>> THAT EVENING EVERYONE WILL
REVOLUTION.
WORKER, FAMILY COMMUNITY AND
ESPECIALLY FOR AMERICA.
ON FRIDAY MAKE A WHEREWITHAL
MICHAEL MOORE THERE IS
SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT HE SAID
TO BE CHILLING TO BE HONEST.
>> I THINK THAT THERE WILL BE
SUCH A LANDSLIDE AGAINST THE
TRADERS 1983 AND CANADAY VOTED
EVERY CONSERVATIVE MEMBER
EXCEPT FOR TWO OUT OF OFFICE.
[APPLAUSE]
BUT FOUR YEARS LATER IN GREAT
BRITAIN EVERY CONSERVATIVE
MEMBER OF THE BRITISH
PARLIAMENT IN SCOTLAND AND
WALES FROM NORTHERN IRELAND
WERE OFTEN OUT OF OFFICE.
STEVE: A LANDSLIDE AGAINST THE
TRADERS AND HOW THEY TALK AT
LEAST BILL MARR PUT THEM IN
HIS PLACE.
>> SHUT UP RIGHT NOW.
>> BUT IF IT WAS ONLY MICHAEL
MOORE THIS EXTREMISM IS NOW
MAINSTREAM FROM THE DEMOCRATS
TALK ABOUT BIDEN AND THE
DIVISIVE DEMAGOGUE RECIPE
WEEKS AGO.
>> THOSE REPUBLICANS REPRESENT
EXTREMISM IT IS THE VERY
FOUNDATION OF OUR REPUBLIC AND
THAT IS A THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY.
STEVE: THEIR JUSTIFICATION FOR
THE RHETORICAL INSTALLATION
JANUARY 6 WITH THE SAME PERSON
STARTING MADNESS ALSO SAID
THAT.
>> ON THIS JANUARY DAY
BRINGING AMERICANS TOGETHER
TONIGHT WERE PEOPLE UNITING
OUR NATION WE'RE INDISPOSED
GOVERNOR.
STEVE: HE DID NOT ENDED OUT IN
THE MIDTERM TO HIS OWN
ADVANTAGE DOING THE EXACT
THING THEY ACCUSE EVERYBODY
ELSE OF.
WHY THEY WEAPONIZE THE DOJ AND
FBI FOR THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS PUSHING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND AT THE SAME
TIME PUTTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFF ACTUAL CRIMINALS WITH PRO
CRIMINAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WITH AMERICA'S CITY IN SQUALOR
WITH CRIME AND CHAOS.
A NEW ARMY OF IRS AGENTS
TRAINING THEM IN COMBAT TO
PURSUE POLITICAL OPPONENTS BY
ALLOWING THEIR OWN ACTIVISTS
TO AVOID TAXES THROUGH THE
VOTER REGISTRATION SCHEMES
THAT ILLEGAL ABUSED TIME AFTER
TIME THEY PUSH POLICIES TO
CONTROL EVERYONE ELSE BUT NOT
THEMSELVES AND PROMOTING
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHILE THEIR
KIDS ARE PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND
PROMOTING GUN-CONTROL BUT THEN
THEY STASHED THEIR OWN GUNS
DEFUNDING THE POLICE DRIVING
WITH HER OWNED ONE ON -┘- OF
THEIR OWN PRIVATE SECURITY
THEY CALL REPUBLICANS VIOLENT
EXTREMIST.
BUT A DEMOCRAT POLITICIAN IN
LAS VEGAS WHO BRUTALLY
MURDERED A JOURNALIST.
THIS WEEK AN 18 -YEAR-OLD WAS
BRUTALLY MURDERED LOW DOWN BY
A MAN WHO IS PART OF THE
REPUBLICAN EXTREMIST GROUP NO
WONDER BIDEN WAS CONDEMNING
POLITICAL VIOLENCE UNDER BIDEN
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DESCENDED
INTO THE DEPTH OF CYNICISM AND
EXTREMISM EXACTLY WHAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT FROM A WEEK
CORRUPT TO MEDIOCRE MACHINE
POLITICIAN TOTALLY CONTROLLED
BY THE HARD LEFT ACTIVIST
BASE.
UNBELIEVABLY BIDEN STILL BRAGS
HELD BY A PURSE ONE -┘-
PARTISAN AND THINKING HOW MANY
PEOPLE HE THINKS WE LEFT AND
OFFICE.
>> EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN NEEDS
TO RETURN THE FAVOR AND VOTE
THEM OUT OF OFFICE.
STEVE: WHO DOES HE THINK NEEDS
TO STAY?
THAT MAGGOT - - THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS?
>> HERE THIS AMERICA, EVERY
SINGLE REPUBLICAN, EVERY
SINGLE ONE EVERY SINGLE
ONE, EVERYONE, VOTE THEM OUT
OF OFFICE.
>> EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN
VOTED OUT OF OFFICE?
THAT SOUNDS LIKE MICHAEL
MOORE.
TO WOULD SAY THAT TO BIDEN?
EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN THAT
IS A DEMENTED RAVING THAT IS A
ONE-PARTY STATE AND THOSE WHO
LECTURE ABOUT SAVING DEMOCRACY
NOT JUST REPUBLICANS BUT EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT.
WHAT ABOUT SEMI FASCIST?
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEYOND
CONTEMPT EVERY SPEECH EVERY
TIME HE SETS HIS OWN JUSTICE
SYSTEM HE STINKS FURTHER INTO
THE MIND.
IT IS DISGRACEFUL.
TRULY A DISGRACE.
LET'S BE BETTER THAN THEM
BECAUSE I SAID ON FRIDAY
AMERICANS ARE SICK OF THE
EXTREMISM.
THEY WERE PRACTICAL COMM